france 24 est la première présente
bonjour bienvenue dans l'hebdo votre
mère votre émission consacrée à
l'actualité de ces territoires français
à la une cette semaine la crise à
m'tsapéré à mayotte les habitants
protestent contre l'insécurité reportage
à découvrir dans cette édition a tout de
suite
[Musique]
mais d'abord fini l'obligation vaccinale
en nouvelle calédonie une décision votée
cette semaine par la commission
permanente du congrès à 8 voix contre 3
la mesure de lutte contre le convive 19
suscitait de vives oppositions dans
l'île et avait été adoptée en septembre
dernier à plus de dix mille kilomètres
de sa russie natale le quotidien de
cette étudiante s'est assombri à la
réunion à 22 ans christina pense à ses
amis en ukraine et à ses proches russe
qui comme elle espérait que la guerre
serait évitée marie-ange frassati la
rencontre et c'est une journée triste et
difficile pour christina à la réunion
depuis six mois elle est originaire
d'une petite ville au centre de la
russie étudiante en master de sciences
humaines elle a beaucoup de mal à se
concentrer pour réviser ces partielles
depuis ce matin elle espérait que les
tensions entre l'ukraine et la russie ne
dégénérerait pas j'ai des amis qui
habitent là-bas et
ouais bien sûr c'est mon stress beaucoup
et ils partagent des
des photos des vidéos je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne comprend pas ce
qui se passe même que moi j'essaie de
suivre des actualités chaque jour mais
c'est tellement difficile de comprendre
en 21e siècle c'est ça me brise le coeur
que l'on a toujours des guerres hristina
s'interroge que peuvent bien faire les
citoyens pour enrayer cette guerre elle
la russe comprend pas que la plus part
des ukrainiens puisse revendiquer leur
souveraineté c'est vrai que on partage
beaucoup avec le cren de niveau de la
culture mais quand même le cren à sa
propre culture
sa propre langue ses propres traditions
et c'est pas la même chose que la russie
le cren
et indépendante christina étudie pour
devenir un jour interprète sa
contribution à elle sera d'aider les
gens à mieux se comprendre
et sur les côtes du tremblay à la
réunion toujours les opérations de
dépollution du 13 tu as stars sont
suspendus ce pétrolier mauricien échoué
depuis le 3 février dernier il avait été
partiellement vidés par les services sur
place mais n'étant pas payés par
l'armateur est les équipes ont cessé les
travaux le maire de la commune de
saint-philippe appel l'armateur à
prendre ses responsabilités
vont-elles gagner du temps et s'ils
pensent que le nettoyage se fera aux
fruits de la nature il se trompe nous
avons pris la tâche d'un avocat
spécialisé qui défendra les intérêts de
la ville et donc une plainte va être
déposée concrètement sont encore une
fois j'estime qu'il ya eu un manque de
transparence sur le contenu exact du
navire qu'il ya un manque de diligence
de la part de l'armateur
et direction bora bora où des travaux
pèsent sur le quotidien des polynésiens
les occupants du motu de terreau romy
n'ont plus d'eau douce au robinet mais
une eau polluée en cause le projet
personnel d'un riche investisseur sur
cet îlot entre le lagon et l'océan
jacques d'amours
en 2018 en riche financier américain
rachète à gaston tong sang tavana de
bora bora une parcelle sur ce motu a
permis de construire est alors accordé
ainsi qu'une a ôté autrement dit une
autorisation d'occupation temporaire du
domaine public pour la construction d'un
ponton sur lagon huit mois plus tard le
conseil des ministres autorise des
travaux déjà réalisés
qui plus est dénoncé par un collectif et
deux associations des réalisations qui
selon les contestataires ont causé une
forte salinité de la lentille d'eau nous
puissons creuser pour avoir long douce
s'apaiser entre 3 et 4 bet donc en fait
c'est tranché a touchée la nappe
phréatique plusieurs prélèvements
d'échantillons d'eau de la nappe
phréatique ont été réalisés à
l'initiative du collectif appareil à
bora bora les résultats de ces analyses
sont sans appel les taux de salinité
atteignent jusqu'à 7 grammes de sel par
litre d'eau soit une augmentation de
plus de six points en quelques mois
seulement conséquence la petite société
familiale d'agriculture installé sur le
motu se retrouvent anéanti autre dommage
la destruction massive de l'importante
assises de corail lors de la
construction de la buse d'aspiration
d'homère océanique contactés ni le
tavana debora broye ni le ministre de
l'environnement n'ont donné suite à
notre demande d'interview
la colère aussi des habitants de
m'tsapéré à mayotte coupés du monde
depuis le week end dernier ils ont érigé
des barrages sur les routes déterminés à
faire entendre leur ras-le-bol face à
l'insécurité qui gangrène le territoire
pour l'heure la localité n'entrevoit pas
de sortie de crise reportage al dali 10
as à dire à sa fille est née
dans un village coupé du monde ils font
régulièrement le tour pour mobiliser la
population
wasquehal soumagne agréé vous on n'est
pas là pour détruire des cases ont
chassé des étrangers nous voulons que la
population de m'tsapéré soient unis on
arrête les violences parmi eux des
riverains excédés mais surtout des
victimes des bandes armées car les
agressions continues en marge du
mouvement cet homme s'est fait attaquer
par une vingtaine de jeunes ce week end
ils m'ont demandé mon téléphone quand
jésus dit non et re s ont commencé à
m'adresser y
est j'ai il avait des machettes des
ferrailles donc moi ce que j'ai pu j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu faire c'est
découvrir
pendant que les plus jeunes défilent sur
les barricades les femmes et les aînés
mène la cadence
je suis là chef ici c'est moi qui
érigeait ce barrage vous savez c'est
juste là à côté que le jeune homme a
reçu un coup de machette sur la tête
effectivement je reconnais ce sont nos
enfants qui sont à l'origine de toutes
ces violences mais lorsque je le corrige
je ne veux pas que les autorités m'ont
empêche cette infirmière est l'une des
rares à pouvoir passer ce matin ça fait
trois quatre jours que ça dure mais bon
on fait avec pour les autres il faut
faire demi tour une situation que chacun
accepte avec philosophie
depuis que la situation a dégénéré aucun
client ne passe dans mon épicerie mais
c'est normal parce que ces hommes
d'affairé la violence a dépassé les
limites il faut qu'il y ait des comités
dans chaque quartier
l'état doit se réveiller nous sommes
fatigués je fais de la tension à chaque
explosion je suis prise de panique
malgré tous les efforts des autorités
pour bloquer les manifestants à
l'intérieur de me appéré régulièrement
la rocade ici est bloqué par des
barrages et des manifestants c'est un
travail de recherche et de compilation
inédit un recueil sur la diversité des
recettes d outre-mer babette de rozières
l'a remis au ministre d outre mer lundi
c'est lui qui avait confié cette mission
à la chef cuisinière guadeloupéen elle a
donc sillonné les territoires depuis
juillet 2021 pour promouvoir
l'authenticité de ces régions
ultramarines le patrimoine culinaire
l'un des arguments pilier pour l'office
du tourisme guyanais mais tous les
moyens sont bons pour attirer les
visiteurs alors la destination guyane
s'offre le coup de pouce d'influenceurs
de la région et l'opération porte déjà
ses fruits alexandra gilbert et sefiane
dei
début de matinée sportif pour ces quatre
influenceurs ils découvrent leur
programme au fur et à mesure et les
surprises semblent à leur goût à l'image
de cette séance de temps vous pousse toi
il ya de l'énergie à de l'émotion il ya
vraiment elle sent que qui a dû passer
dans la danse chaque mouvement a une
signification et sept jours pour
jennyfer c'est une première en guyane
ludo lui était déjà venu et trouvent des
ponts entre son île la martinique et ce
bout d'amazonie c'est le bel est chez
nous le dernier et la belliard on a
entendu alors quand ces sommets ce démo
comprend pourquoi ce goût ici est
franchement très de quatre cavaliers
allemands surtout après le sport le
réconfort mais il faudra y mettre du
sien le chef doris mirta les attend pour
la préparation d'un blaff baptisé
schmitt est ce cette opération donne à
voir le territoire au travers de route
ou lhimer
ariel a le courage de s'essayer la
première l exercice après moins de 24
heures passées ensemble le groupe semble
déjà bien fonctionné ces voyages d'
influence sont très en vogue pour les
destinations touristiques un moyen plus
économique qu'une campagne publicitaire
est plus efficace aussi c4 influenceurs
posteront des photos et des story toute
la journée pendant tout leur voyage nous
on s'est dit rien de mieux que des
influenceurs pour plus faire voir et
revoir notre territoire fait revoir le
centre littoral et là on a choisi des
influenceurs par rapport à la cible
antilles guyane et antilles et guyane
est de métropole et donc c'est parfait
on aura au moins minimum je pense 80
minutes les résultats de l'opération ne
se sont pas fait attendre le comité de
tourisme du centre littoral a déjà
observé une hausse significative du
nombre de vues et d'abonnés en seulement
24 heures
enfin l'histoire du carnaval
martiniquais retracé en un lieu
l'association beau canal en a fait sa
mission grâce aux pièces recueillies au
fil des ans elle tient sa propre
exposition jusqu'au mercredi des cendres
un petit musée découvert pour vous par
dominique legros et marc balle ça
c'est ici au siège de l'association beau
canal qu'une bonne partie de l'histoire
du carnaval va se raconter les diables
rouges les carolines filolie les masses
à l'ens monique consorts sortiront de
l'ombre juste pour quelques jours depuis
plusieurs années ce petit musée de
fortune s'étoffe de vestiges du carnaval
chaque pièce a son histoire chaque pièce
est le rappel d'un plan de la culture
africaine et martiniquaise on a mis en
place en qualif en aval qui va croire
pouvoir vivre ces jours là où toute la
1re chambre à venir les oignons et nous
revenons à nos bases pour permettre à
nos enfants du plus jeune des rois de la
matière pour continuer ce travail de
recherche 7,4 tuer des acteurs tout est
symbole et signification comme on
l'indiqué à césaire en casamance les
miroirs mis côte à côte sur les costumes
représentera connaissance les cornes de
bovidés c'est la richesse temporel la
richesse spirituelle c'est dans cet
esprit que marie-luce confectionne les
masques et des costumes
les matériaux sont achetés ou cole est
excellent alors les matières sas et on
l'achète
les casses
on l'achète
tout ce qui en achètent aussi et le
papier 60 et seulement qu'on n'achète
pas la peau de vache s'achète su non ça
s'achète pas ça ça on ne donne à
l'abattoir à l'abattoir l'econo cissé à
l'abattoir
pendant les jours gras tous les
personnages emblématiques tous les
symboles du carnaval seront exposés dans
cette maisonnette qu'ils appellent kayak
en aval mais aussi dehors dans la cour
des conférences sont prévues sur le
carnaval et seront animées par des
spécialistes
merci de votre attention c'est la fin de
cette édition pour la revoir direction
france 24 points comme hélas premiere.fr
retrouvons nous le week end prochain
l'information continue sur france 24
[Musique]